les stars et la chirurgie esthétique est
obligatoire passé un certain âge de
passer par le bistouri pour avoir une
carrière regarder mal et on en parle
juste après avait une des premières
femmes à assumer le fait d'avoir fait
par exemple un petit peu de change
esthétique c'est que je veux beaucoup en
plein milieu du visage le nez en 97
rien de folie a parlé sans détour de ses
opérations de chirurgie esthétique
s'ils ont envie de faire des choses il
faut les faire et puis on est libres 1
surtout oui mais la chanteuse a eu de la
chance parce qu'entre les mentons d'igor
et grichka le visage boursouflé de
berlusconi et les seins de nabila il y à
prendre et à laisser
si je puis me permettre
la nature même retouché reste
parfaitement injuste alors que jane
fonda 80 ans au compteur semble avoir
trouvé la formule magique tout comme
sophie marceau 51 non contrairement à
gwyneth paltrow qui vient de nous en
faire une belle elle s'est mariée le 29
septembre dernier et on a profité selon
quelques invités à rien mais disons pour
faire un lifting complet mais vraiment
complet c'est la première fois que je
voyais à un mariage des invités vérifier
qu'il ne s'était pas trompé sur
l'identité de la marine
heureusement avec les nouveaux
traitements après quelques mois ça
dégonfle
parce qu'avant la fin des années 90 on
utilisait des produits non résorbables
résultats définitifs
mieux valait ne pas avoir la main lourde
et annuel béart en 2012 déclare l
expérience effroyable j'ai fait refaire
ma bouche à l'âge de 27 ans n'est une
énigme pour personne c'est loupé
aujourd'hui je pourrais dire je suis
contre la chirurgie esthétique
encore faux semblant de rien même s'il
n'y a plus que quelques paparazzi
aguerris pour les reconnaître encore
n'est-ce pas mickey rourke
[Musique]
oh
pour être bankable les stars
doivent-elles avoir recours au bistouri
la chirurgie pour rester au top
oui ou non vous savez une question à
d'ailleurs merci vous pourrez ajouter un
stack tnp qui peuvent tous pensé de
l'émission des sujets vous aimez vous
aimez pas ce que vous pensez voilà on
lit tout et puis on essaie de
s'améliorer et la question voilà c'est
les stars et la chirurgie esthétique
c'est nécessaire pour perdurer ou c'est
nul il faut assumer son âge on a ici une
professionnelle notamment de la charge
dès cet été
pardon elle en parle semag et terre
s'est mise à magali j'aime pas trop
costaud aujourd'hui on dirait un cocker
à sa tombe est très belle mais j'aime
bien quand il n'ya plus d'emploi je vous
reprends mon premier métier
[Rires]
team aqua fait et je lui ai dit qu'ils
passaient you really want avec ma
sociaux est bon et tous les autres alors
chirurgie esthétique est que c'est
nécessaire vous dit non vous alors j'ai
alors que va dire la vérité
jenas et mais alors je dis non parce que
à un moment donné on n'a pas forcé et
les femmes n'ont pas besoin pour être au
top il sent bien
et bah elles ont droit de ne pas le
faire il n'y a pas de problème moi je
les fais mais cependant depuis que j'ai
refait mais dans par exemple revit
excusez-moi abbas mentir je revis je
peux sourire je peux je me sens bien je
me sens moi-même etc
mais ça c'est une question personnelle
par contre pour être au top et pour
rester au top
j'estime que on n'a pas nécessairement
besoin de chirurgie esthétique ça c'est
pas vrai on sait bien que c'est un
métier d'image oui dans ce métier vous
pensez que c'est nécessaire très
difficile
toutes les stars vous le diront et je
vois je ne connais pas une personnalité
de la télé août les deux du cinéma ou de
la chanson qui ne fait pas au minimum un
peu de botox est un petit peu d'acide
hyaluronique
tout le monde le fait mais c'est normal
et difficile longue mais bien triste
juste quelques citations agile parce
qu'évidemment toutes celles qui n'ont
fait le regrette assez bizarrement jean
et robert se trouve vraiment dommage de
voir que nous avons une société
totalement paniquée déformés ou les
femmes ne veulent même pas savoir à quoi
elle ressemble sur notre rampling pas de
chirurgie esthétique je suis trop
curieuse de me voir évoluer au fil des
années
charles gainsbourg mon père m'a dit que
ce serait la pire erreur que j agric
ouverte avait avant à merveilleux grand
nez à la fenêtre chirurgie
c'était plus rien après là quand on
décide tout elle regrette mais à la
fripe la chirurgie donne l'effet inverse
de l'effet attendu
cameron diaz je préfère voir mon visage
vieillir plutôt que d'avoir les l'air
défait de quelqu'un d'autre bref
calmes et honnête elles le font tout bas
où elles vous disent qu'elles veulent
pas c'est pas de la chirurgie fardeau
chirurgie esthétique quand on parle de
botox et d'assister la beauté ouais
c'est différent tous est que j'ai cités
n'ont pas fait évidemment mais non c'est
pas ça catherine c'est qu'aujourd'hui
évidemment la chose dick a beaucoup
évolué et aujourd'hui c'est plus des
vieux livres sting ou tirer comme il ya
des modes mais il ya des modes amant et
faber le nez aie aie a pas très
longtemps toutes les filles se faisait
faire les lèvres tu regardes duo un
magazine je ne peux pas la récupérer
cette démo d'aliens d'oreillettes est en
deuil
non mais c'est pas bien c'est valérie
lemercier qui l'a dit c'est l'inversé
qui n'a dit bref à comment presti non
c'est vrai a su réveiller à faire tu as
caché le reste est vrai que je veux dire
à tous alors pardon il est tôt il
croyait il ya une grande mode des
sinistres blanchiment d'avis tout faire
la main comme quoi ça la question en ce
cas de avant après la vague d'achats
isabelle adjani là ils sont un peu mais
cholet 20 ans isabelle adjani à bord
après on affame henderson la caisse
comprend pas que personne ne leur dise
voilà qui à dos tourné ces tribunaux si
mary j voilà et c'est pas la plus moche
faux témoin donatella versace là c'est
quand même un poil trop
c'est un point
toi negra yonne à la meg ryan moi c'est
horrible c'était une idole de jeunesse
rebelle y regarder ces défis les plus
belles du monde
elles ont toutes la même bouche est
opaque la même bouille des grosses bomag
grosse laine injectent des choses parce
qu'en vieillissant ya moins de gras dans
les jours c'est la famille bogdanov
alors il passe tout juste à daniel je
sais que ça vous intéresse beaucoup
quelques chiffres de quatrième
alors désolé guillaume j'ai pas le
montant du blanchiment d'anus un lifting
ça coûte quand on donc on se fait bien
lifté ça coûte entre 2 à 6000 euros
selon le chirurgien à ce qu'on fait une
des piqûres de botox et 250 à 300 euros
l'acide héros nick pareil et enlever les
taches au laser sur les tâches du
vieillissement c'est environ 100 euros
si tous à environ 100 euros
oui alors sébastien oui alors ce qu'on
est ce un choc et l'ua pour vous c'est
normal par bus vous qui êtes beaucoup
aux états unis vous voyez ça mais alors
moi c'est très simple il ya une rue près
de rodez audard qui s'appelle camden là
il ya eu des cliniques les plus connus
se mettait dans un petit café en face on
attendait que les stars sortent parce
qu'on connaît les voitures on les
suivait on attendait qui s'arrête
quelque part pour les faire soit un peu
gonflé ce qu'il sortait du botox ce soit
avec un truc sur le nez etc
ça c'était le grand jeu dont vous avez
vu beaucoup aimé y en avait quasiment
tous les jours avec maquettes des quads
et tom cruise des gens comme ça d'être
tous ceux que vous avez cités même des
petites starlettes tout le monde y passe
et pour quand c'était sur le visage on
le voyait après évidemment si c'était
ailleurs on voyait pas automatiquement
n'ont pas donné mais maintenant il ya un
gros problème qui se pose c'est que aux
états unis ça commence à être considéré
comme une maladie mentale quand ça
devient exagère ils appellent ça la
dysmorphophobie il ya il ya une clinique
qui s'est créée qui s'appelle la
clinique mayo qui est assez secrète où
les agents et les studios envoie les
stars parce que ça commence à devenir un
problème parce que il le leur écurie
commence à diminuer parce qu'il ya des
stars qui peuvent plus tourner tellement
ils ont été défigurés par la clinique on
peut se désintoxiquer sexuellement pour
ceux qui ont trop besoin de six à dix
avant technique pour tous les lyonnais
en europe possédant division sedanais
n'ont su éviter si vous avez un peu de
temps pour y aller peut-être oui d'après
ce que je voudrais ça va regarder toutes
ces photos c'est les plus belles ces
défis les plus belles qui se mêlent
je ne comprends pas alors attention
bienvenue sur fr3 je vais prendre un
exemple trail mathieu tout à l'heure
marthe villalonga reverte est pas la
photo d'un photo n'existe pas j'adore
marthe villalonga les c'était pas une
affaire n'a rien fait elle appelait
naguère le 85 ans elle est magnifique
attention quand même la vie est bien
faite parce que quand vos rides
apparaissent la vue de votre baril
baisse donc tout va bien ne fait pas de
lâcher leur geste et c'est une belle
qu'on est toujours étrange documents
mais mon avis le qatar abdallah d'arabie